archivo is one of my favorite typefaces  archivo a popular free font on google  fonts got a major upgrade 108 styles of  an upgrade  i mentioned before how the fonts on  google fonts have gotten better you  should still look closely at any font  before selecting and some free fonts are  hit or miss  keep in mind even with the updates the  archival super family has quirks but for  free dollars and free cents and built  into tons of google apps i think it's  versatile i wrote this script in google  docs archivo  anyway the design of archival reminds me  of a grotesque like helvetica or  universe but just enough quirks for it  to feel unique on its own its round  characters are slightly square the  italic f descends the double story g has  a lot of unusually flat moments there  are many similar details that makes it  feel more rugged or drop proof  and that's why